[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chris sorte émises doute on lit salut ça
va
fabien toi super j'ai fait un rêve
bizarre par contre j'étais enfermé dans
un placard est quelqu'un que tu es la
variété française très très fort c'est
cool on à qui ce matin monsieur valentin
simonet 47 ans annoncé sa première fois
je ne sais pas bien pourquoi j'ai peur
des chiens en fait si vous allez rire
corinne et éleveuse canine mais je me
demande si ça vient pas de ma mère parce
qu'elle était tout le temps dans le
contrôle et l âge essais de manu pardon
les montes tu feras compagnie madame
s'il te plaît vous en prie installez
vous dans le fauteuil
mais 13e cm2 nous avait raconté
l'histoire d'un chien toto est bon mais
on a je vous arrête tout de suite mais
votre histoire de deep non résolus et
votre transfert sur votre prof de maths
ça m'intéresse pas du tout je vais juste
vous endormir pénétré votre cerveau
trouver le souvenir qui vous traumatisme
ou le supprimer vous réveillez vous
signez là voilà c'est écrit qu'elle veut
conserver nos souvenirs oui absolument
en fait nous sommes dans l'obligation
légale de conserver vos souvenirs effacé
et vos data sur un serveur aucun vous
souhaiteriez revenir en arrière à
travers a très bien merci
ah je vois que vous avez choisi chopin
excellent choix c'est parti
à mon avis ça date un traumatisme lié à
l'enfance ou une humiliation rassure
vous fier alors moi je t'ai galy sur
grosses chiennes assez de titres et
ballons perdus ça c'est à moi aulas voit
la sensation pas ça non donc bah il a
juste été mordu par ailleurs cher quand
il était petit c'est très décevant
bon bah je supprimer plus de l'egypte
tu fais quoi là rien je supprime son
goût pour les pornos qui avilissent les
femmes je lui installer des goûts
sexuels un poil plus progressistes il
nous a pas demandé de faire ça ça va
crise qu'on n'a pas le droit
qu'est ce que tu peux être chiant ouf
c'est bon je les gect capitale s'il vous
plaît merci ça a été si on voit salut
merci
chris faut que je te parle et je sais
que noël c'est un moment un peu
compliqué pour toi mais cette année
j'aimerais vraiment essayé de le passer
avec ma famille d'accord il manque donc
je pense que je vais aller les voir à
new york
ça fait super longtemps que je n'ai pas
vu d'accord après j'ai pas envie de te
laisser tout seul mais j'ai vraiment
envie d'essayer de reconnecter avec eux
tu comprends d'accord si j'avais mes
parents je ferai probablement pareil
barak à venir avec moi ouais carrément
banide est trop cool un parfait bon
allez je me suis produit annie
[Musique]
oh
à